Film Courage: Two kinds of
writing, creating and shaping?
Glenn Gers, Screenwriter: There are two
kinds of writing and every piece of writing
uses both kinds. It’s not like somebody only
does creating and somebody only does the shaping.
Every writer has to get used to sort of
an over and over again process of creating
(what I call creating) and it’s just the stuff
that comes out, what some people call the vomit
draft or the experience of just trying to imagine
stuff and write down what you think trying to put
yourself in a scene or think what would they
say next and write it down. You’re accessing
something that truly humanity has no idea what
it is or where it comes from. I don’t know if
it’s something that other creatures have but
people have this weird ability to make stuff up,
it’s essentially dreaming. You think of a story or
a character or a moment or a scene or a line and
you don't you can't really say where it comes from
and this is every artist in history has experience
has described the same experience of I was trying
to write this thing and this line just came to me
this scene this twist whatever it is it just comes
to you and the more that you can get used to the
need to let it happen however it happens to create
without any judgment at all without any criticism
without any fear saying anything that comes out
of me at this moment is fine and to be able to
sustain that and do that for a bit of time and get
something down and to get used to the experience
of making that written down feeling free with
the words even if they're bad even if if you're
bad at typing they're going to be misspelled
doesn't matter what matters is that they
you grab them from that mysterious place and you
get them on the paper that's creating but then
almost always it's going to need some shaping
some editing some rethinking writing rewriting
and that second shaping part is where you say
clean up all the typos break that long sentence
into two short ones make those two short ones
into one long one that word there that's really
vague what do I mean when I say baffled baffle
is actually pretty specific but what I mean
that do you start to think the way someone who's
not you would read it and whether they would get
the experience you're trying to give them and
then you start to be mechanical about it there's
tricks you can use putting the punch line at
the end putting the set up at the beginning
finding funny sounding words for funny
lines there's all these tricks of the trade
that goes in the shaping part when you're shaping
you're spending a lot of time being critical
and trying to when you're critical what you're
trying to do is I like to think of critical
as making the best of not saying bad i'm not
critical of it I am wow there's a funny bit in
that but this is getting in the way so critically
i'm going to get rid of the stuff that's in the
way of the good I like the good what's important
about being critical is that you're doing it to
improve what it is trying to be not make it into
something else and certainly not just slam it down
the editing part of you the rewriting part of
you is the second part of the process usually
it goes back and forth several times sometimes
you get weirdly creative while you're editing
a new line comes to you and then you so
you're sort of doing a micro switch editing
editing oh the new line creative oh back to
editing and that process goes over and over
most writers I know they tend to set aside
a separate mood I know i'm going to have to
do seven days of creating creating craving
i'm never going look back at what I wrote
and i'm just going every day set aside an hour
throw it down and then go make myself a nice lunch
then for another seven days i'm going to look at
what I wrote take a big deep breath start to break
it down start to do the work stretch a little
go back to it and that process over and over
will make for great writing do you think too
many writers are focused on positive feedback
instead of writing something that can actually be
made that's interesting actually I do think that
we have developed a script reading industry within
the industry and that has sort of become a kind of
I don't know what the term is for like if you've
got a river and it suddenly gets like a little
backwater and things get stuck in there instead
of going with the flow but that's there is that
people who are writing scripts are unfortunately
mostly writing them to be judged by people whose
jobs is to read them that could be professional
script readers and critics it can also be anyone
who is an executive or a producer their job is
to read a script and try and figure out if that
script is going to be producible but still they're
they're working on the script many many people who
are in those fields don't know anything about
production they don't know anything about making
a movie and in fact when I say movie I mean
movie or show or filmed entertainment of any kind
the most important thing for a screenwriter
because it's a particular kind of writer
is that you are writing for production there is
no value to your writing until it is produced
someone may pay you money which is value in the
sense that they think it's going to get produced
but truthfully the value is if that script can
be acted and directed and edited and released
and there's different qualities which
are valuable to the people doing the
acting directing editing than the readers
and you need to be able to please both
because you can't get to the production
people without going through the readers
so I would say you need to learn
all the advice about how to please
a reader and what they're looking for
and what they the rules they have and
everybody tells you different rules
but know as many rules as you can
but still it's very important to understand
what happens when a script gets made if you can
make it yourself write a script for the purpose
of making it yourself just so that you learn what
happens when an actor has to say lines one
of the things that happens is you'll learn
most of the lines that you wrote were probably
information in other words you were thinking
I need the audience to know this thing so I'll
write a line where somebody says it in some way
but what the actor and the director and the editor
need is for the character to need to say something
totally different the character has to need to
say the information if they don't need to say
it it's not going to work for the actor and the
director the only way that you can learn that
is by having actors and directors work with
your script if you are a diy type of person
try it find a way to at this point you can do
it on your phone you can get a bunch of actors
from the nearby community theater or college write
something that's appropriate to their ability of
talent and try it out it's going to take you some
time it's going to be some heartache there's going
to be some arguments but you will learn how your
script is transformed by the production process
what works and doesn't work and that is incredibly
valuable to everyone who eventually will make the
movie and if you can learn that stuff by and
you can pretty much only learn it by doing it
then you will be a screenwriter who's making
something not just to get approval but to actually
get made and be good so by running these lines by
these actors and filming it with your phone you're
finding out what's filler in the dialogue and
what is an actor or character wanting something
portraying that to another character who also
wants something what it really will come down
to is you'll learn what dramatic action is because
dialogue is action when somebody speaks actually
in real life too you're trying to do something
like when you go to a counter and say may I have
a pack of cigarettes well don't say that say say
may I have a club soda and a lottery ticket yeah
when you say that it's because you're trying to
accomplish something when you say to someone I
love you or I don't love you anymore it's because
you're trying to accomplish something you're
trying to make something happen or get something
you're trying to change your relationship with
them you're trying to get something some of them
to do something all dialogue should be action
that's what an actor needs to play and that's
what a director needs to direct is that almost
every writer you'll meet especially the ones who
have not been in production will think in terms of
information this dialogue is conveying this
information and they can make it sound nice
but if it's not actually action if the character
is not trying to change something in that moment
it's not going to play by the way the other thing
I wanted to say was i'm a fan of DIY and I think
that we should demystify it the point of DIY
filmmaking is mostly not to get your big break
and to have it sell for a billion dollars it's to
get experience it's the it's the same thing that
the the the ten thousand hours Malcolm Gladwell in
oh gosh I can't remember the name of the book now
Malcolm Gladwell publicize this phrase
Outliers is Malcolm Gladwell's Outliers
ten thousand hours is what it takes to be real
mastery of any particular thing you're doing
it took me like 30 000 because i'm really stubborn
and slow but that process for a screenwriter
has to include the production and what
happened was the the indie industry
blew up in the the 80s and 90s over somebody makes
a 3 000 movie and it sells a billion dollars and
and they're great for the rest of their career
and so everyone started making movies for that
aim for every one of those that was huge there
were thousands that lost all their money and
the important thing to know about DIY is you're
going to lose all your money the you might as well
grab a lottery ticket to try and make money off
of of indie filmmaking but that's not the point
the point is to do the work and get it to an
audience to get in production and if you don't
feel like DIYing yourself there are people who
are wanting to DIY who can't write and they will
love you if you just want to write and give it to
them so the important thing about that is the same
thing that the 10 000 hours taught The Beatles
when they went to hamburg and they had to play
eight hour sets every day for weeks and weeks
on end supposedly that's when they got good
the work they were doing was not
necessarily their best work but they were
producing their work and putting it in front
of an audience and doing it again the next day
that's the important thing that screenwriters are
not given the opportunity to do you're not going
to be given that opportunity so you should take
it yourself do it a nice safe way like I said if
you're a writer and you don't feel like producing
find people out there they want good scripts
when you were attempt for those 12 years was there
one story that you really clung to of your own of
your own writing that you thought this is going to
be it or were you constantly working on new things
well I did have this one script that kept on
getting passed around and people liked for those
10 years and eventually it did sell so that that
for those who out there yeah 10 years it can still
sell and frankly after that 10 years 10 years
after that it was still being shown and people
were showing interest in it so that's one of the
important things that you should remember when you
write something and you're thinking this will be
my break it might be your break in the sense that
people recognize your talent through it and they
never make that but it becomes quote a show script
that's a perfectly valuable thing I got a lot
of show scripts I thought they were going to
be big hits I thought they were going to make me a
fortune but they were just something that somebody
read and said wow you're a good writer why don't
you write this thing that I think will make money
that's still a valid reason to write
a script and the script still exists
somebody doesn't buy it it's not like it gets
burned somebody else later on might like it.
Question For The Viewers: Creating or
shaping, which one is easier for you?